DEENA SHAKIR: And I'm
thrilled to introduce you
to my good friend Christopher
Schroeder who literally
just flew in from DC
on the last flight
before they shut
down the airport.
So big round of
applause to Chris
for actually making
his way out here.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: Thank you.
DEENA SHAKIR: Chris and I first
met three or four years ago
when I was working at
the State Department
and actually helped put together
the first Presidential Summit
on Entrepreneurship
in the Middle East.
Chris is a long-time
internet entrepreneur.
The vast majority of his
career up until recently
has not been spent working
on the Middle East.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER: No.
DEENA SHAKIR: But I'd love
for him to come and tell us
about his story, what got
him interested in the region,
and what ultimately proliferated
in this really groundbreaking
book called "Startup Rising,
The Entrepreneurial Revolution
Remaking the Middle East."
It's filled with stories
of incredible entrepreneurs
who have traversed
trying circumstances
and represent stories of hope
in the region that really paint
a different picture than
what we hear in mainstream
media about what's going on.
Stories of young
women and older men
all over the Middle
East from North Africa
to Saudi Arabia who
are really coming up
with amazing innovations in the
internet space specifically,
and I think will represent
an entirely new feature
for the region.
So without further ado, I'd
like to turn it over to Chris.
And I just have some informal
questions to get it going,
but feel free to talk about
anything that comes to mind.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: Awesome.
DEENA SHAKIR: To start,
if you could just tell us
a bit about yourself
and how you got
interested in entrepreneurship
in the Middle East.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: So it's
wonderful to see all of you.
Thank you for coming out.
This is a counter narrative
story in many respects,
and I have to tell you it
doesn't surprise me out here
that people want to come
hear counter narratives,
but it's been very
surprising to me
throughout the
launch of the book
about how people just can't get
their minds around a hopeful
narrative in the
Middle East, and I'll
come back to the distinction
between hopefulness
and optimism in a moment.
But this is not only a very
hopeful story about the Middle
East, but it's a
very hopeful story
about the rest of the world
as I think so many of you
know in many powerful ways.
Look, I've been an
American-based internet
entrepreneur consumer facing
internet ad-based businesses
as an interpreter.
I ran all the online businesses
for "The Washington Post"
and "Newsweek" and
"Slate" some years ago.
And then broke off
from that and then
got a bunch of people
together, including
Mike Moritz of
Sequoia and started
the social and content
platform on health and wellness
called Health Central.
And so we built that out of the
east coast with some operations
here and around the
country, and sold
that a year and a half ago.
And that's when I had some time
to go dig into this narrative.
But how I came to it I think
was very accidental because it
really is a journey
of narrative bias,
and I think it's one of the
great cautions for all of us
in business and in
life generally speaking
about what narrative
animals we really
are as people, because
we like our story.
Right?
Now, each one of you
has a story about me.
You have a story about
being in Silicon Valley.
You have a story
about being at Google.
You have a story about
where you're from.
We all have stories.
And the stories are unbelievably
important because from then we
can act, from them we can
think about what to do in life.
But the challenge, of
course, of a narrative
is if you get
biased by it, you're
actually missing
obvious things that
are happening
around you, which is
how the world can
change a powerful ways.
And it's particularly surprising
I think even an environment
like this, where you would never
think you would have narrative
bias but, in fact, you do.
And the journey for
me narrative bias
is particularly embarrassing
because in the three
internet companies
that I've run,
I have outsourced technology
to pretty much every corner
of the world.
Right?
South America, Eastern Europe,
Sri Lanka, India, of course,
Israel, and I've
traveled probably
to 85 countries in my life.
So I've been everywhere.
And I could not get
it through my mind
and through the narrative that
we have in the United States
about the Middle East that
Mubarak's Egypt at this point
was kicking up an
ecosystem in technology
that we've seen everywhere.
And it's particularly surprising
because you guys know better
than anybody that if there
is, in fact, ubiquitous access
to broadband technology,
everything changes.
You see everyone, you can
interact with everyone,
see the way the world works
in very, very powerful ways.
Totally underestimated
is the fact
that everyone's now essentially
got all of human knowledge
at their fingertips
essentially for free.
I mean, this is a
universal, and yet
so strong was my narrative bias
that I couldn't believe it.
I had helped form a group of
American CEOs and Arab CEOs
shortly after September
11, and as one
of the members of the
Arab side said recently,
we're kind of saying
why do we do this?
I can't remember.
It was 2004, and one
of them said, well,
we did it to prove to each other
that we're not all assholes.
And in a way it was true.
It was, in fact,
our attempt having
gotten to meet each other
through another business form
and having built
a lot of respect
among each other personally
to realize that we all
had narrative bias and
at this very crucial time
after September 11, it
was important to think
about it in different ways.
And so it was a huge agenda.
We weren't doing
business per se,
but we would meet in one
city in the United States
and one city in Europe and
then one city in the region,
and we would bring to bear
resources and relationships
we had from business, and
politics, and journalism,
and the blogosphere, or
whatever and just really to get
to understand each other better.
2009 or so two really
extraordinary entrepreneurs
from the Middle
East, one is a man
named Fadi Ghandour
who you know.
Fadi was-- he's just amazing.
I haven't met five people
like him in business anywhere,
but he was a builder of
Aramex, built it from nothing,
and Aramex is effectively
the FedEx in the Middle
East and Africa, and he just was
one of the great entrepreneurs
to do this.
But he then very
soon became and is
today one of the real
anchors of the ecosystem.
Someone in TechCrunch
described him
as the Ron Conway
of the Middle East.
And so I'm not sure either of
those guys like that analogy,
but it is what it is.
In a way, it describes
him a little bit.
The other guy is Arif Naqvi who
is actually Pakistani but has
spent much time
in the Middle East
and built now what
is one of the,
I think the new largest
private equity firms
for emerging growth
markets anywhere.
It's called Abraaj Capital
earning $10 billion.
Anyway 2009, they
started talking
about the new
generation taking hold
of new technology in
very powerful ways.
And most of us gringos
were just like, yeah,
that's a cute side show,
but that's not interesting.
Let's talk about peace process.
Let's talk about it.
Whatever.
And they said, no man.
This is something different.
It is really, really different,
and they put their moneys
where their mouth
was in 2010, and they
had this enormous
gathering in Dubai,
which is called Celebration
of Entrepreneurship,
and some of you probably
were even there.
But it was 2,400 mostly young
people from North Africa
to Yemen with a waiting
list of another 2,500.
No one wanted to talk
about Obama's Cairo speech.
Nobody wanted to
talk about anything
other than building
their businesses,
and using technology in
really interesting ways,
in ways that you all
would have felt completely
comfortable in it.
And it was, as
naive as it sounds,
it was for me kind of my
life and my world view
has shifted from before that
event and after the event.
Matter of fact, I extended
my trip, and I went to Cairo,
and I went to Amman,
and I saw more of it
literally by the
hundreds if not thousands
and realized that there
was something very big here
and that it was not just
something that was remarkable
about the Middle East, that the
United States should understand
and being in business
should understand.
But really it was pulling
on an enormous string
about how the world is changing.
DEENA SHAKIR: An
incredible story.
I'm curious if there was a
particular watershed moment
for you in the
various experiences
that you just described
where you realized
you were impelled
to write this book.
You realized that
there's a story here
that you can help tell.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: Well, yeah.
I mean, there were
1,000 stories,
and the act of just watching
this dynamic in and of itself
was, I think, so powerful.
But then you have a lot
of these ah-ha moments
that you pull on themes that
you guys live, I think, day in
and day out.
So for example, I had this
young guy from Alexandria, Egypt
who was pitching me an
app development business,
and I sort of listening
to him and trying
to figure out what
he was talking about.
It sounded very familiar to me.
And I looked down on
my iPad and realized
I downloaded it six months
earlier having no idea that it
was 30 young people
in Alexandria, Egypt
who had done it.
No clue because
it didn't matter.
All I knew was it was beautiful,
it worked, and it had become
then and is now
the largest selling
paid weather app on Earth.
It's like seven million
downloads now, 40% of which
is in the United States.
They don't have any
operations here.
So you have that as kind
of one of the stories
of our time about how things
are changing globally.
Probably a third of
the entrepreneurs I met
just look at almost
every infrastructure
problem as a software problem.
Right?
This is the story of our time.
They're like two fundamental
stories of our time
that I think come
out from this, which
are powerful in the
Middle East but there's
a much broader than that.
One is, that we have this
ability now to really view
almost any problem like
a software problem.
And so guys my age
or older will say,
the traffic sucks
in Cairo, so it's
going to take a generation
to fix the roads.
And I can tell you I've
seen a dozen ways like apps
to navigate traffic
to work around it,
and that kind of stuff.
Education is really
tough in the region.
The public school
education-- actually,
this was surprising to me.
And forgive me for
seconds for talking
about the region as a
region because obviously,
every country is very different.
Culture is very different
in every country and all,
but if you can
bear with me being
aggregate for a second overall.
It's actually stunning
in a per capita basis
how much is spent in
education in the Middle East
in public school to
these terrible outcomes.
Because classroom size can
average 70 kids are more.
Literacy is terrible
particularly
in rural parts of
places overall.
The testing and the teaching
is incredibly rote learning.
So it's just memorization driven
into you, but almost none of it
has anything to do
with the 21st century.
Right?
And it's not like hard-core
engineering or mathematics
and all.
I think the best indication I
could give to you to give you
kind of the sense of
the magnitude of it
is that in Cairo alone
the supplemental education
business is like $2
to $3 billion a year.
All right?
So what dos that tell you?
It tells you education
sucks, and it tells you
that the rich people are
taking care of their own.
Right?
So what happens when you look
at the problems as a software
problem?
As you can imagine
they're now like probably
20% of the startups
that I've seen
in Egypt in the last
year in some form
are like a Khan
Academy in Arabic.
Right?
And there could be videos
if you have access to video,
but because so many people
have only texting phones,
they're actually coming
up with really interesting
supplementary tools and
games that they're doing it
in education that way
because you view the world
as a software problem
that can be fixed.
So you've got these
incredible problem solvers
that just sort of blew
me away in that way.
You have this idea that
everything can be global
overnight as a way that
we know, and therefore,
innovation as well is just
good products and services can
come from different
corners of the world,
and it's a story of our time.
Because the fact is, as you guys
know and Andreessen wrote it
in the forward of my book,
in the next eight years,
pick your date, there are
going to be five billion-- Eric
talks about it--
they're going to be
five billion smartphones
on the planet.
And it never ceases to amaze
me how so many people think
at the end of the day,
still, in this day and age
that a smartphone is about
like better features,
or maybe about better
multimedia experience.
And we all know it is
about better features
and it is about multimedia,
but that's not the story.
The story is that
five billion people
are going to walk around-- in
Egypt, the mobile providers-- I
keep coming back to Egypt,
because the stories come
from there right now, but this
is true in Amman and elsewhere.
Every mobile provider
that I interviewed
for this book told me that
within now two years then
three years, they'll be
50% or 60% smartphone
penetration there.
Right?
And in the Gulf, by the way,
it's already beyond that.
So what are we saying?
We're saying that half of
humanity, 2/3 of humanity
are walking around
with supercomputers
in their pockets,
and that obviously
means that problem something
changes, innovation changes,
and people have a very
different hopeful look.
Because in a lot
of respects, this
is the true definition
of empowerment.
Empowerment is a tossed-around
word in many, many ways,
but when you have the ability
to feel like you're not alone,
to feel like you're not crazy
in what you're thinking you can
do, and then you see
someone else like you do it,
that means that
you can do it, then
it becomes this
flywheel of success.
And that's
psychologically as much
as technologically
and business wise
I think what's been
happening in the Middle
East over the last
five years or so.
And that to me was just totally
uplifting, and fascinating,
and I think a story, not
just about the region,
but about the world.
DEENA SHAKIR: One
of the things that I
think is so compelling about
what you've done with this book
as someone who has spent
almost a decade now working
on promoting entrepreneurship
in the Middle East
is that you've taken it
out of this relegated realm
of development and
sort of aid, which
is where a lot of
entrepreneurship programs
were focused in.
And you've elevated it to the
ranks where you have Andreessen
writing your forward and Ben
Horowitz hosting book events
and Reid Hoffman
writing a narrative.
So if you could speak about
how you see entrepreneurship
in the Middle East,
not only being good
for the Middle East but
being good for the world,
being good for internet,
startups in general,
being good for investors
based in Silicon Valley
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
Well, I mean, there's
a lot of different questions
with different kinds
of approaches to it.
I mean, if you are
one of the top venture
capitalists in Silicon Valley
and you've got the ability
to effectively see
the best of the best
deals in this incredible
network of effective talent,
you're going to be focused here.
And there's a reason why
Andreessen and Horowitz were
very focused here and Sequoia
and others have expanded
to other places, but still
the lion's share of the focus
is here because they can.
They can see the
best of the best,
and it is that kind of a thing.
And in fact, it was actually
kind of interesting to me
because one of the more
interesting things that I
did when I wrote this
book is I actually
spent a couple of weeks
out here interviewing
a lot of my friends, both in
the venture capital industry.
I interviewed some of your
folks here and everywhere else.
And the string that I was
pulling on for them was,
so how is the next
five years going
to be different than
the last five years?
I mean, something
different is happening.
We know this is happening.
So how are you
thinking about this?
And they said almost
to a woman and a man,
almost to a woman and a man,
three things that were similar.
The first thing that they
said is, look, you know,
if in fact, there's a market
that's big enough for us,
then we have to pay attention.
We may lose a lot
of money in China.
And by the way, one of
the unwritten stories
in Silicon Valley is that
they've all lost a lot of money
in China.
They're not been great.
This is not a well-known
story, but it's true.
No one is really
sort of-- I mean,
I guess if you were to have
the ability to buy [INAUDIBLE]
in $0.10 or whatever,
you'll do just fine.
But I'm just saying that
generally speaking this
is a tough slog, because
emerging markets are not
for the faint of heart.
But if the market is
that big and you say,
well, I'm willing to lose
money for a period of time,
and I'll figure
out how to beat it.
Me, me, me.
The second thing that people
said, very consistently
is, well look, if
I can outsource
what I'm doing cheaply,
then I'll do that.
Why wouldn't I do that?
Me, me, me.
I'm like, OK.
That's great, but let me ask you
an interesting question, which
is if we're dealing now
in a world where we have
ubiquitous access to software,
where people, in fact, would
like to be part of their
home and their culture
and they have opportunities
now of entire rising
middle classes and large
markets of consumers,
don't you think you need to
think about that differently?
Isn't it possible that
some great innovation
will come from a
part of the world
that we don't think about
now in a typical sense?
And invariably the answer was,
if the talent is that good,
and the ideas are
that innovative,
and they're that hungry,
they'll come to Silicon Valley.
And so it's a very, very
interesting kind of framework,
and I would suggest
narrative bias even here.
It's not just like
anywhere else where
I think folks are
going to be saying,
I mean, you've probably seen
this and I can't find it,
but I was looking
for the other day.
But there was a
study that came out
that said more Indians actually
went back to India than came
to the United States for the
first time in like 50 years.
And these guys
when they say to me
they will come to
Silicon Valley,
I say, they would love to visit.
They'd love to have
business partnerships here.
Some of them would
like to come here,
but a lot of them, if they
can, would like to stay home,
and how do you want to
engage in that world
because now they can.
And I think it's
an open question.
I haven't seen a
whole lot of answers
to that yet except that
I think like most things,
there's a ripple effect.
And so all of a
sudden when people
see the impact that
you guys had in Egypt
or when other people see
that the tech operating
companies have built a huge
footprint across the Middle
East-- LinkedIn just
opened up offices there;
Paypal just opened
up offices there--
when you start to see that,
then you start to say something
may happen.
Dave McClure, 500
startups, declared
that the Geeks on the plane
he was going to do this year
was in the Middle East.
Nobody had any idea.
They were like, what the hell--
where did that come from?
And he had a great
time, and he interviewed
the entrepreneurs who went
and the investors who went
and they were blown away also.
So I think it's a
timing thing, but it's
a timing thing who has ankle
weights of narrative bias
even from the
investment community.
DEENA SHAKIR: I couldn't
put the book down
when I was reading
it, and I think
what makes it so
compelling is really
the stories of
these entrepreneurs
that you interviewed.
Can you share with us
some of your favorites
that really speak to the
diversity of the innovations
and the innovators
in the region?
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER: So
I hate answering favorites
because even the
businesses that I met
and the entrepreneurs I
met who probably weren't
this fundable first time,
were fundable the second time.
So I mean, that to me,
it's hard to pick them out.
But there are a couple-- I
mean, you touched on this
almost in passing, but this
is a huge counter narrative.
"The Economist"
wrote this summer
and it's hard to prove it,
but I can tell you anecdotally
that I totally agree with it.
But "The Economist"
wrote this summer
that 25% of the startup
entrepreneurs in the Middle
East are women, total
counter narrative.
And I could tell you that
I was a judge at a startup
competition that MIT puts
on with the local providers,
the enterprise form in
Beirut a year and a half ago.
5,000, 6,000 companies,
15,000, 16,000 entrepreneurs.
That year, 40% of
them were women.
And so this is to me one
of the awesome things,
and I've interviewed the women,
interviewed probably 50 women
for other writing that I did for
"Pandodaily" and for this book,
and it was unbelievably
interesting to see
their reactions to me.
Because as you can imagine
everyone has their own story.
Everyone has their own
experience and everything else,
but if I had the
bucket it, there
are two fundamental reactions
I got from the women
entrepreneurs, and one of them
was like these women getting
right into my grid, like
she just got into my face,
and she said, I will not
be in your women's chapter.
If you're writing a
chapter about women,
you Americans always
want to do this.
I'm not going to do this.
I am not a woman entrepreneur,
I'm an entrepreneur.
If you want to talk
about my business,
I'm happy to talk about my
business, but do not bucket me.
The second reaction-- yeah.
DEENA SHAKIR: That
sounds like May Habib.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER: I'll
name no names, but I will say--
DEENA SHAKIR: I went
to college with her.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER: --but
I'll say you're very good.
You're very good.
But the second bucket
was something like this,
e-commerce is a huge
opportunity in the Middle East
just to put it in perspective.
It's probably a billion,
billion and a half dollars
in e-commerce right now.
The total movement of
goods and not including
or any of that stuff
is $450 billion.
Credit cards aren't really
use much online yet.
I mean, this is a
huge opportunity.
And believe it or not, one
of the real opportunities
there is Saudi
Arabia because that's
where a lot of per
capita wealth is.
And so everyone is
trying to get there.
So I remember
interviewing this woman
with a great e-commerce
idea very, very good idea.
And she said, let
me be real here,
like I'll give you the same
answer that May Habib gave
or anyone else gave
except for this thing
that I need to do
business in Saudi
and I can't drive
when I'm there.
And other women would talk
about let's be realistic,
when I got to see a male
venture capitalists,
they don't treat me-- they
want to ask for my husband.
So you get this
whole kind of litany,
but what was so moving to me
was that in wherever they were
in that spectrum, there was
one thing that I heard over
and over again from every
entrepreneur, which was, look,
the definition of a
great entrepreneur
is the ability to
work around stuff
and get around
problems and headaches.
We're better than
that than anybody,
and I thought that was
actually a very compelling kind
of an overview about
where that was happening.
So that almost is a class
and some of the business
they were building there
I thought were fantastic.
Among the problem solvers
there was this great guy--
forgive me for
picking on Egypt today
because this really is
a phenomenon everywhere.
So this is my last Egypt one.
You have to make sure I don't
talk about Egypt anymore.
But who knew that
the largest aquifer
of fresh water on the planet is
under the desert between Egypt
and Libya?
I didn't.
And the only challenge
to getting the waters
is the ability to
pump it affordability.
And up until now, medium-sized,
large, and small farmers
have pumped it by using
diesel fuel, which
is totally subsidize and utterly
unreliable in its delivery.
So if you ever
fly in over Egypt,
and you're flying
over the Nile Delta,
you'll see it's
unbelievably lush and green
and then becomes white.
And yet under that, of course,
are these amounts water,
so it's a matter of
getting it and so on.
But the diesel was an issue.
Well, two things happened.
One, in all the political
transition that's going on,
they killed the
subsidy for diesel.
So now the there's
a price parity
for other forms of energy
to be brought to bear.
So what happens, an
entrepreneur pops up and says,
I've got a great capability
at a very affordable price
to build solar powered
pumpings farm by farm by farm.
And he believes
just without a doubt
that he can increase
arable land in Egypt
by 25% over the next decade
just by making these ubiquitous
and easy-to-access an
easy-to-use service.
Problems are very low, cost
ongoing very, very low,
no issues about delivery,
obviously, by definition.
Look, let's say he's off by
90%, that's still a huge impact,
not only in terms of what
he's developing there
and a technology that could
be scalable elsewhere,
but in terms of a
country like Egypt
now in such an interesting
period, stuff like that
just blows away.
DEENA SHAKIR: Excellent.
Well, I want to make sure
we have time for questions
from the audience,
and otherwise, I
could chat with you
all day as you know.
Any questions at this point
from folks in the audience?
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: I was talking
about the challenge of rote
learning there as well,
and how do you crack that code?
And it's a very
tough code to crack,
because this is a story of a
lot of emerging growth markets.
And what I was
starting to say was,
we had a young high
school kid from Vietnam
to stay with us for a
while and what have you.
Now, our kids are in one
of the top private schools
in Washington, which means it's
one of the top private schools,
whatever.
He has to repeat the
year when he goes back
to Vietnam because they're
convinced that he can't get
as good an education spending
a year in this school.
And he literally won the
DC, Maryland, Virginia math
competition in like
the first three months.
He's just a brilliant
kids and wonderful guy.
But I got talking to him one
night and I said, so tell me,
I mean, this was like--
is this easy for you,
or what do you think about this?
He said, no.
Some of it's very hard.
Some of it like just problem
solving, I could do that.
That's great.
But no, he said it's
really exciting.
So I said, so what
do you find exciting?
I figured you might
be bored, and he
said you're engineering club.
And I said, well,
what do you mean?
And he said because
you guys tinker.
And I said, what do you mean?
He said we never tinker.
We never tinker.
He said, I can tell you
stuff about nuclear energy
that college kids
can't tell you about,
and I can't apply
it to anything.
There's no application.
And so the ability to
have a sense of tinkering,
a sense of application
is something
which I think is an issue in a
lot of emerging growth markets.
And I would argue may be a
problem in part of the places
here.
So here's another one of the
just unbelievable phenomenon
to watch, and I can't tell
you that this takes care of it
or what happens.
All I can tell you is it's
unbelievably provocative,
and we couldn't talk about this
if we met five years ago, which
is the phenomenon that I'm
describing in the Middle East
is utterly bottom up.
Like there's no Lee Kuan
Yew in the Middle East.
I mean, the king
of Jordan has been
supportive of the
ecosystems sometimes.
Dubai is opening up
interesting things,
but Dubai is very expensive to
live for young entrepreneurs.
And a lot of folks are beginning
to ask interesting questions
now, but this is fundamentally
a bottom-up phenomenon.
This is merely by having
access and by having
some good engineering
from the region
and/or studying the west,
this thing is moving in scale.
And so what is happening
now is like there's
an organization some
of you I'm sure went
to some of their
gatherings called
ArabNet, which holds one of
the biggest regular gatherings
of startups in the Arab world.
But one of the things
they did in the last year
is they've broken it down
to now a series of very
small gatherings to help the
C engineers learn from the B's
and the A's to sort of up
the game for everybody there.
And so there's the sense of
autodidact of shared learning
that's coming in
the physical world,
not just in an online
world, which I think
is one surprisingly scalable
and highly impactful.
Wamda.com, which is
another great institution.
I'm sort of on the board
of advisors for them,
but they have this series
called mix and mentor, which
is what they do is, they
get guys like me and women
like me to join a
gathering of 1,000 people
in small tables talking about
whatever mentoring you want.
But I can tell you this
is purely anecdotal,
but it gets to your point about
the autodidact aspect of this.
The first mix and mentor
I did was two years ago,
and pretty much the
young people just wanted
to hear what I had to say.
All the questions
were directed to me,
and that was kind of the
exchange, one on one,
one on one, one on one.
I went to one six
months ago, and I
could have been irrelevant.
What was inter-- the minute
the first question was asked,
someone else at the
table answered it,
and then the table
talked amongst itself.
And it's that sort of
sense of ownership and auto
self-teaching that I think is
going to be the answer to you.
I mean, look, in this hugely
bottom-up world we're facing,
it's not like top down doesn't
matter, like Army's matter.
I mean, stuff matters.
And we've spent no time talking
about the terrible realities,
which are also present there.
I know entrepreneurs
from both Syria and Egypt
who in the last year died.
So I mean, this is a very, very
serious confluence of events,
but at the same time
and in parallel,
something is being opened
up and an opportunity
is available that just
simply wasn't there before.
And that's where I
think it's happening.
Now, I hope top-down
educational institutions will
be able to embrace it
more and maybe it'll
meet somewhere between.
But like that I don't know.
But I do know what
they're doing bottom up.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for speaking with
us, and really great story,
and I'm glad that
you're out there trying
to counter sort of
the narrative fallacy
that many folks have
built up in their head.
And I'm also glad that you
recognize in your comments
the story what's happening
in the Middle East
sounds very similar to
things that are happening
in pockets throughout the world.
So we were recently
in Medene, and you
know what's happening in Medene
sounds similar in Nairobi.
It sounds similar to
what's happening in Amman.
So I was hoping maybe you could
talk a little bit about what
you think this means
specifically to the Middle East
and to the people there, like
what makes this really unique
in the Middle East and
what kinds of impact will
it have on people
there that might
be different than
the impact but you
might see in Medene or Nairobi?
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: I actually
think that the parallels
are in some respects
the more important thing because
not only are they interesting
and sort of making it clear
that this is a global phenomenon
once you have access
to the capabilities,
but at the same time, there
is this wonderful group called
Endeavour Global.
Linda Rottenberg is
the founder of it.
It's the largest
nonprofit that helps
a fast-moving
entrepreneurship, not just
tech based, by the way,
everywhere in the world.
So I've seen this
across the thing.
And there's this thing that she
calls e to e, emerging market
to emerging market.
I think both from a business
opportunity perspective
but also from a psychological
perspective, that
is more, it says
in my book, when
you get great entrepreneurs
in the same room,
they're like the same people
anywhere that they go.
And that aha moment,
that understanding
that all of a sudden I can
be in a room from somebody
from Colombia or
whatever and they're all
wrestling very similar
things and going through
and-- that's huge.
So to me, that's still a
very, very big part of it.
It's always interesting
to see what problems
get solved at scale
in very powerful ways.
Like if we were sitting
here eight years ago
and maybe it's a
surprised to a few of you
today, who would have said that
the number one mobile payment
country on Earth in
aggregate dollars
is Kenya, that 20%
of their entire GDP
passes through a cash-sharing,
texting capability?
And that's never going to work
here in the United States.
It's probably not going to
work in most parts of Africa.
Its even hard for it
to work in Middle East,
because there's a better banking
system for all its problems
as compared to what
Kenya was overall.
But there it happened,
and stop and think
what I'm talking about.
All of a sudden, you
can move cash one day,
and you couldn't move
cash the other day?
Again, a flywheel
multiplier effect
of that throughout
societies are huge.
And so what you're
seeing in the Middle East
though it fits patterns
and other emerging markets
is like here you guys we
can call pick whatever
your favorite company is effect.
But over there, they'll
call it the Maktoob Effect.
And you'll know the Maktoob was
the Yahoo! of the Middle East
that was bought by Yahoo for a
little bit under $200 million.
That was great.
It said you can do this.
It can happen here,
but I think what
was even better
than that was also
you created a bunch of wealthy
younger people, new generation
people, who are now
putting their money back
into the system.
Out of Maktoob, I can name 10
different entrepreneurs who
have now spun off other
companies one of which,
souq.com S-O-U-Q-C-O-M.
This will effect the Amazon
of the Middle East.
This is probably a multi-$100
million company now.
That flywheel thing
that's happening there
in terms of its
issues and opportunity
I think within the
Arab world is huge,
because last
observation, unlike say
Turkey, which has an awesome
ecosystem, amazing talent
there.
It will blow you away,
particularly in Istanbul.
At the end of the day, if you're
creating a startup in Turkish,
you're in a very limited market.
And the factors are
many things that
make the different countries,
societies, cultures, towns,
villages differ within
the Middle East,
but they're very active.
I mean, 350 million people with
a shared language, most of whom
really only speak that
language, which represent,
what is it 7% or 9% of the
total speakers on Earth
where less than 1% of
content online is Arabic.
Those opportunities are
one unbelievably manifest,
and two have a wonderfully
multiplier effect in that way.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering
about how people perceive
failure in that
part of the world.
So I think here we look upon
it a little more favorably.
If you fail fast, if you have
a string of failures behind you
and you're looking
for support, people
understand that
you've had experience
and you've learned your
lesson, but maybe not so
much elsewhere.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: I don't
think that there's any question
for all the hypie hubris that
sometimes comes
with our innovation
here that our willingness
to bounce off of failure
is very powerful,
which, of course,
which I tell people often
in emerging markets,
it's not the same thing as
saying that failure doesn't
suck because it's terrible.
And I think sometimes
we overplay that myth,
because I think-- I don't know.
You guys probably know
people around you who failed,
and you're kind of
like, all right.
Good for them.
They failed, and other people is
like you don't feel about them
quite the same way, and
so that's human nature.
But the fact that
it is in our ethos,
so that's part of what you
do and you have to move on.
It's huge, and it's one of
the greatest limitations
I found in Argentina, in Chile.
I mean, this is a different
kind of mentality.
But go back to what I said about
when you have ubiquitous access
to information, and to each
other, and to all information.
You start to realize if
it's happening everywhere
in the world, I'm not crazy
that maybe this one's not
working out.
And it has, again, I think this
success breeds success aspect
of it.
So this is purely anecdotal,
but it will give you
a sense of it, because
the fear of failure thing
was really brought
up to me often
when I first started my
journey going over there.
And in fact, in some
countries, believe it or not,
technically, it's
criminal to fail.
Like there's no bankruptcy
law, so you literally
could go to jail for not
doing what you've done.
And so there's
structural elements,
which are not heavily
enforced but they're there,
and that's part of
the psyche as well.
So I mean, these are very,
very profound things.
Anyway it was at
another huge gathering
where the former ICT minister
of Jordan who actually
had done success in
business in Amman
and elsewhere overall
spent the time
answer-- I was moderating him,
and he answered a question
just describing his outright
failure in one of his ventures.
And I turned to him and
I said to him, Arwon,
I've never seen this happen.
And he said, what?
And I said you've just
been talking openly
in front of 800
people about failure.
I said, are your mind?
He said, look, I'm
so tired of this,
and he looked out to the
audience and he said, come on.
How many of you at some
point failed somewhere?
And 2/3 of the hands went up.
So again, bottom up, from
a different perspective.
Parents are very
concerned about their kids
stepping off of what they view
to be a tried and true path.
There's a tremendous
sensitivity to this still,
but there's something also
happening in parallel.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a
Silicon Valley person
who relocated to South
Africa, and I do work
across sub-Saharan Africa, and
a lot of what you're saying here
really resonates with me.
One thing that I'm curious
about is at a policy level,
and you kind of touched on
this a little bit earlier
with the bankruptcy being
illegal in some areas comment.
What are governments doing at a
policy level in the Middle East
to either help entrepreneurs
or hinder them?
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
The answer is, not enough.
And by the way, this goes to
the United States government
as well.
Deena, I'm sorry.
And the risk when they
start to think about it
is that they could
actually make it worse.
Right?
I mean, that's always
the kind of off
that happens when they
get involved with this.
But where I guess I come out
overall is the amount of impact
that they can make
to take friction out
of the ecosystem there to help
the circumstances that you
describe as profound.
So let me give you
obvious example.
E-commerce is I think
an enormous opportunity
over there.
As someone described to me
trying to simply move goods
from one country to
another is like Bezos
trying to build
Amazon with 50 States,
with 50 State regulation
bodies, different fees,
different inspectors.
It's crazy.
It's literally sometimes cheaper
to ship something from Jordan
to the States to Dubai than
across-- not true in Dubai now,
because they're moving
these things pretty quick.
But there's a huge opportunity
just to ease that code
or to unify that code.
And one of the
things that I learned
is actually there's been some
pretty smart stuff passed,
but nobody still
pays attention to it.
So the GCC, the Gulf
countries, which
now include Jordan and
Morocco actually do
have some very interesting
code about making
it very easy to
trade among them.
That's a wonderful place
to start if that helps.
And so if that
happens, it's great.
The opportunity is
profound and just literally
taking friction out making
the ability to getting
permanent ease it's likes
more basic stuff I think
can have an enormous
effect overall.
I think our government has
a huge opportunity to be
supporting what's going on there
without it being a top-down,
let's-pat-the-entrepreneurs-on-the-head
kind of thing,
and there is that proclivity
in my city to do that.
And I'll never forget, I think
I helped, you probably did it,
but I helped them get off
of this when they'd show up
at almost every gathering to
talk about the number one US
export is entrepreneurship.
And there's nothing like
talking to societies
of 10,000 years who've been
entrepreneurs the whole time
and telling them you gave
them entrepreneurship
to sort of kill the whole thing.
But this is a whole
digression, but I'm
a fanatic on the
immigration issue,
and I'm even a fanatic on H-1B
visas and then just quick visas
overall.
There was a great
entrepreneur that I met,
wonderful company
and idea who got
recruited not by one but
two Silicon Valley firms
here to invest in them, and
this was in April of last year.
So you've got to be here
by the first week of June.
We can't do this one
over Google Hangout.
You've got to be here,
and we're looking
at two other companies
in the States,
but we're willing
to talk about this,
but you've got to go
toe-to-toe if you want to come,
you've got to do that.
And they went down
to our embassy,
and our embassy said, wow.
That's a great idea.
Come back in August and
we'll interview you.
And so it's these kinds of
things, which aren't that big,
aren't that sexy, but
the ramifications of them
are unbelievable.
AUDIENCE: So I don't know
if it's a perception issue,
but it seems like they're not
a lot of successes coming out
in the Middle East, like even
like going to the Middle East,
I don't see a lot of successes,
Maktoob obviously, is
the biggest one.
What do you see are
like the obstacles?
Is it mentorship?
Is it government regulations?
Is it like lack of
technical skills?
Like what is prohibiting like
a lot these entrepreneurs
from moving on to
the next level?
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
So a couple of things.
I mean, one, the litany that you
just gave are all challenges.
Everything you
mentioned are things
that are being worked
on, and history will only
tell us whether they've
been working on fast enough
or a bottom-up can move fast
enough to be truly globally
competitive.
And we just talked about
the government aspect of it,
which is clearly part of it.
The second observation
I would make
and I don't totally agree
with what I'm about to say,
but I've been working
my brain around it
in any event which is,
I think sometimes we
put too much emphasis
around exit as the indicator
of success with an ecosystem,
and I think they do
matter because they
matter psychologically.
I mean Turkey had four or five
$200+ million technology exits
of different types within
the last two to three years,
and there's no question that
helps that though, of course,
that has a spread even outside.
Turkey and the Arab world
is obviously different,
but there's still some sense of
connection that it can be done.
And even in the Caucasus and
in parts of the former Soviet
Union, it has a huge
multiplier effect.
But there's a lot
of stuff that we
don't hear about too, which
is kind of unfortunate.
So again, Souq.com, I don't
know souq.com's numbers,
so I'm not revealing
anything here,
but they just raise
a boatload of money
from a blue chip Western
venture investor,
and I'm just
telling you my guess
is from what I've
seen of it and I
do know a sense of the volume
of the goods they move.
This most have been a multi-$100
million quote unquote exit
though it's not an exit,
but this company is going
gangbusters.
Now all of a sudden
lots of people over here
want in souq.com if they can
figure out a way to get there.
Nobody knows this one.
This one just blew
me away, and when
I gave it to TechCrunch
and others to write about,
nobody would take it finally
Kara Swisher let me write it
up, which is like six
weeks after Mubarak fell,
Intel bought a mobile
engineering company in Cairo
of like 250 engineers
called SySDSoft,
but no one heard about it.
I mean, for god's sake, man.
I mean, this is six
weeks after Mubarak fell
and Intel is doubling
down in Cairo.
What does that tell you?
And they're actually
lots of those,
but we don't hear about
them I think quite as much.
But to tell you
just to acknowledge
the other side of
it, Maktoob is still
the one that's still
talked about most,
and that's now three,
four years ago.
Now, let us also
say that they've
been busy the last two years.
And I think that if we see
some of this evening out,
I know a few companies
that could go out.
The public markets are
not that great yet.
Having said that,
if I were to ask you
what was one of the largest
tech broadly-defined IPOs
in the world this year,
what would you tell me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
That will be, that is.
No.
But this is a company
called Asiacell,
which is the mobile
provider for Iraq.
and it went public at over,
and now it's over $6 billion
in market count.
Who the hell in the midst
of all the news that we hear
about Iraq would know that
their largest cell provider,
mobile provider went
public back in March?
AUDIENCE: Follow up
to Basel's question
about the ecosystem
in terms of, there's
a lot of challenges, of course,
corruption and enablement
that the government does
to help entrepreneurs
succeed and whatnot.
But also from what I've seen
in Ramallah for example,
there's a lot of movements, and
even SADARA Venture Capital now
got money from google.org.
They were hoping to get
a number of companies,
I think three companies a
year and over three years
they got like two.
And it's been a great
challenge to-- not only
the technical talent is
there, but the attitudes
of the teams and
the entrepreneurs
is the biggest challenge.
There is a lack of trust.
There is a lot of different
sections in groups,
and people kind of
associate themselves
with one party over the other.
And that's common whether
at the religious level
or at the village level.
Like if you look in Palestine,
for example, every village
has its own
association, and you're
part of this group,
now part of that,
and it's been really challenging
to just get them together
around a business.
The perception from
Middle Eastern perspective
is, we always have to be
like buddies and brothers
to be able to do business.
From your perspective, like
how can this be overcome,
and what can be done to improve
and scale that over time?
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
Well, a couple of reactions,
one, I think it's just
everything you've described
is totally true and real.
I will tell you,
by the way, you saw
that one of the two companies
is a travel company.
I forget its name.
Do you remember the name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
Just got more money.
Yeah.
I'm sorry, that's right.
They just got more money.
That's good.
I mean it's not six deals, but
it's two deals, and one of them
at least seems to be doing
pretty well, and also
a very chaotic time with that.
This idea about being loving
each other and everything
else, I mean, come on, man.
Look in your backyard.
I mean, for god's sake,
there's a lot of coopetition
and a lot of
cooperation, and there's
a lot of shared
learning for sure,
but I've got scars
from Microsoft.
Someone else in this
room must have them.
I mean, this is also part
of dynamics of being in it,
not to in any way say that
the distinctions culturally
and societally that
you describe are not
a compounding aspect of it.
And I think it's a big question.
I think we'll have
to see what happens.
And I could tell you
that if he were here,
I don't want to talk for him.
He's a remarkable man named
Usama Fayyad, that some of you
know who was up until
recently has been running
Oasis 500, which is one of
the larger and more successful
incubators out of Jordan.
And he would tell you that
that's probably his number one
concern, what you
described, because he
said getting the
young people in here
not just working together,
but working hard, working
for long periods
of time, and then
once they've been
incubated to not have
recidivism to other behaviors.
He said it's just something
that the only way to do
is to keep at it, and
at the end of the day,
the more and more
companies have started
to compete with other companies
that are doing the same.
Either they're going
to or they're not,
and we'll just have to
see how that plays out.
But there's no light switch.
There's no class
that could be taught
in Khan Academy
that fixes that one.
I think it's just
a matter of-- you
know, it I'm no economist,
nor am I a psychiatrist
or psychologist, but I can
tell you having run businesses
and just seeing the
kind of dynamics,
this whole idea of wanting to up
your game because other people
around you are upping your game
or the number of entrepreneurs
who told me after
the Arab uprisings
that this is something
that's bigger than me.
I want to make a
successful company.
I want to make
money, but this is
my life, not my parent's life.
I now have an opportunity
to do something
they've never done
before, and if I
do that, I can say
something good about Jordan.
I can say some about the region.
I mean, that's all
new dynamic also
and how much that
counterbalances
some of the other things that
you've described so well,
I can't tell you.
All I can tell you
is it's different.
DEENA SHAKIR: So I have a
question for you, one more.
One of the things that
we've talked about a lot,
and you know that I've worked on
quite a bit before coming here
is, diaspora entrepreneurship.
So I'm from Iraq, and there
are a lot of other folks
in this room from places
that they can't go back to.
What role can the
diaspora play in helping
to be a part of this
movement, and what stories
do you have to share
about some who have?
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: So you guys
know this better than anyone.
Nobody was better at harnessing
the diaspora population
to unbelievable success to the
home country, to the diaspora,
and to the country, the United
States or at large than TiE
and the efforts by India,
which is mind blowing what's
been done over the last
25 or 30 years of that.
And thank goodness
that we have TechWadi,
which has been around
for actually a long time
to try to harness the broader
community here as well
as the diaspora
population more broadly,
and I think with
the Arab uprisings,
everything sort
of-- we want to see
what things were looking like.
And now these guys are
hugely back in business
in terms of doing this.
And I think that there's
an enormous opportunity now
to do it differently.
I mean TiE was about a
lot of physical events
and physical connections because
that was done 20 years ago.
But the ability to connect
now with diaspora for money,
for expertise, for market
opening could never be greater.
And we now have the
tools, the capabilities
to do it profoundly different
ways I think is well.
So it's not the well tapped yet.
I think TechWadi is
the best that there is,
and it's in it's earlier
re days of what's
going to be a very big
days for going forward.
And I think it's one of the
most exciting initiatives
that they're doing,
not just in terms
of connecting the
region, which is finding
great entrepreneurs
who are at large,
but this is an enormous,
enormous opportunity
that I think we'll see much,
much more going forward.
DEENA SHAKIR: And just
to follow up on that,
I think one of the untold
stories about Dubai
is the role that it's playing in
this diaspora entrepreneurship
revolution, and
even May Habib who
we talked about who's a
friend of mine and many others
that you highlighted in
your book, are actually,
they're certainly not Emirati.
They may be Arab
Canadian like May
or Arab America like Pam Anneke.
Can you talk a bit about what
you've experienced in the time
they spent in Dubai and
what kind of ecosystem
they're building for
entrepreneurship.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
So Dubai is, I mean,
you guys have been there.
You know it's an
extraordinary place.
Whenever anybody has doubt about
can this happen in the Middle
East?
I tell them just come and
stand in a street in Dubai.
This conference I
described to you before,
Celebration of Entrepreneurship,
was a complete desert
13 years before I stood there.
I mean, the whole thing
was just it's a mind blow
that we have this city with
over two million people,
the vast majority of which are
from everywhere in the world
and it has sprung up.
It has become this huge working,
functioning place there.
Again, from a pure startup,
ecosystem prospective,
the good news is the
technology works,
the good news is that
people are supportive of it,
the good news is that you've
got this incredible hub
of transportation,
so it's not surprise
that e-commerce companies
want to be there.
There's a great
media and advertising
side that's beginning
to build there.
That's all the good news.
I think the tougher news is
it's just a very special place
to live, and that's
tough on entrepreneurs.
There's not even
like a little area
where you can go that
is like parts of Beirut
and others where you can
really live affordability
and sort of hunker down
and do what you're doing.
But I think the ramifications
of it is enormous.
They're about to build
a second version of it.
Abu Dhabi is doing some really
interesting things overall.
It's really interesting.
DEENA SHAKIR: And is
still trying to catch up.
I think we have one more
question over there.
I'll just repeat it.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: You know, I
think the answer is yes.
Right?
I mean, it can be both.
It doesn't have to be
mutually exclusive.
So Saudi, there's this
very interesting thing.
A friend of mine sent-- and
stop and think about it.
Let me give you a down side
and an up side, all right?
So he just sent me a
photograph of the new invoices.
I don't know if you saw
this but Saudi passed laws
just like last couple weeks
the said all invoices in Saudi
must be in Arabic, all of them.
Well, OK.
I mean, the French
tried this 10 years ago,
and it's a statement of
pride, and that's great.
On the other hand,
the fact of the matter
is that business now is global.
It's not just one thing.
And anything that puts
friction in business
in this amazingly,
globally-competitive world
needs to be thought of twice.
But the idea-- and I used to
say this about the French also,
who were trying to put
everything in French
and you had language
requirements and any content
of any video programming
that was created
and everything else had to be,
and everything else-- I said,
look.
At the end of the day, they're
not mutually exclusive.
If my theory is
correct or better put,
if what I'm
observing is correct,
that there is now
just an enormous shift
to the sort of sense that
bottom up can succeed and take
care of their own destinies
and build large market that's
in and of themselves, by
definition, local language,
culture is going to have
on the positive aspects,
by the way of culture, not
just the challenging ones--
are going to have enormous
benefit and reinforcement
within that.
But with that also
comes this sense, again,
as I described
before, did you see
the way the rest
of the world works.
You read what the rest
of the world has written
and so you need to be
able to engage as well.
And so I guess my
answer is that both
are wonderful except
when they cause friction.
And that should be
the thing that's
thought about as people
think about what they want
to do and innovate in that part.
But describing is I did before,
which is an absolute truism,
to have that many people
who speak only one
language at that scale which
so little is available for them
in that language, the only
thing that cries out to me
is opportunity.
That's just opportunity.
And by the way, if you
narrow that gap effectively,
I think the thing
that you're raising
is going to happen anyway.
And it doesn't preclude
all the other stuff
that's happened that's
instantly global as well.
DEENA SHAKIR: I think
we have time for one
more quick question, and
then we'll wrap it up.
Anybody has one?
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
We went over time.
DEENA SHAKIR: We did,
but Eric's in our time.
Yes.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
So this is I mean,
it's wonderful that you
finally got to this question.
As you can imagine
when I'm in New York,
it's the first question I get.
DEENA SHAKIR: I'll repeat
the question really quickly.
So your question is
about the interaction
between Israeli startups
and Arab startups?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DEENA SHAKIR: Yeah.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
You can speak to this
more eloquently than I can,
but it was very striking to me
because, again, in a bottom-up
world, the opportunity
for this kind of
engagement is profound.
And trust me, there's no
where I go in the region
where they're not aware that
arguably the second truly
awesome ecosystem
outside of Silicon Valley
is arguably Israel versus almost
anywhere else in the States.
It's an extraordinary
thing where you just
have to give it what it is.
An engineering
caliber is what it is.
Some very good companies
that are built is what it is.
I know many, many stories
of startup nation being
converted into
slide presentations
and presented to the
senior most people in many
of these governments to sort of
think about that kind of stuff.
So there's sort of this oddity
that you have this thing there
that could be a resource
and an engagement,
and to your question, very
quietly, very bottom up,
a new generation
of people are sort
of doing what they're doing
in kind of interesting ways.
But one of the things--
I'm only reporting here,
so if I'm off base sharing
a better observation, first
of all, the minute anyone
tries to add politics into this
to make it into policy
it's like dead in the water
right then and there.
And secondly, the very
act of the engagement
starts to raise
political things.
So I'll never forget
this young man
who said to me
someone said to him,
he said there is no
wall in the internet.
You don't have to worry
about how terrible it
is across borders
and all the things
that you've probably experienced
if not seen and read about.
But there is no
wall on the internet
to which the other person
responded, well who
the hell cares.
There's a wall.
It can't be totally
disaggregated,
the circumstances there
and the opportunity that
presents itself.
But the thing that happens
in bottom-up worlds
and entrepreneurs is that
interesting stuff still
happens.
So young people have
often come to me and said,
so you mean I shouldn't try.
I'm like, look, man.
I'm an entrepreneur.
Try everything.
I mean try everything.
But there are realities
embedded in that
which are quite remarkable.
DEENA SHAKIR: Well, that's a
great note to end on, Chris.
CHRISTOPHER M. SCHROEDER:
Thanks, Deena, for doing this.
DEENA SHAKIR: Thank you
so much for joining us.
Thank all of you for coming.
CHRISTOPHER M.
SCHROEDER: Thank you
guys for spending time with me.
DEENA SHAKIR: Chris' book
is available for the first--